thank you
hey ladies and gentlemen what's going on
out there today it's Tuesday right you
don't sound like you're sure I'm not
sure
it's Tuesday I forgot for a second we
watched that original Dracula last night
that's right it was good belugosi yeah
there was a lot in this movie that I
forgot about
stuff there was stuff in it I was like
oh man I forgot that was in there
I hadn't seen it in a long long time I
hadn't either actually and I think I was
a kid the last time I saw all of it sat
down and watched all of it because uh
there's a lot of stuff in there that I
didn't remember until I saw it again and
I was like oh yeah yeah like uh like the
fact that
Dracula's whole Harem is in it if it's
vampire women it's a harem it's got
three of them he's trying to add a
fourth one to the harem yeah but um
and he does bringing them to England
doesn't he or is he leaving no he leaves
him back in Romania yeah he's like screw
those [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna make more
that's what I mean he's tired of them
probably with him for over 100 years
he's like well you know they they can
fend for themselves I'm sure
yeah go around um another thing that was
in it was Lucy was in it
and they imply that she went after her
baby they never really showed it though
did they yeah that's the thing they
really did uh okay so I hadn't seen the
original 1931 Dracula for a really long
time
um a couple things I had forgotten I had
forgotten how wildly different this was
than the book like I knew that it was
different from the book but I didn't
realize it was as different as it was
and I didn't realize too because this
was pre-haze code
um I kind of thought they could have
gotten away with a little bit more but
they really didn't like everything was
um pretty much like censored so they
showed like hardly anything like there's
no there's actually no point where they
show Bella Lugosi like with his mouth on
anyone's neck or like everything is
implication or like cut away yeah
he never does so it's like really really
interesting how
how they do that
and one thing that I was watching
earlier like I haven't seen the Spanish
language version of it but before we you
know came on here I was watching a video
about that was like comparing the two
movies and apparently like the Spanish
language version like they could get
away with a lot more in there so it was
like a lot longer and they showed a lot
more things than the than the US version
did so it was really interesting like
every comparison everybody's seeing the
Spanish version is better
it's it's the same sets it's just a
different cast different director and
they they were able to do more with the
script I'd like to see it it's the exact
same scripts too they use the same
script the reason why the movie is
longer is because Todd Browning who
directed the US version like cut out a
lot more or they had to cut out a lot
more
um you know I kind of feel like from
what I could determine like watching the
comparison video it looks like the
Spanish language version in terms of uh
just like dynamism like in terms of the
way that it's shot like it has like a
lot more Dynamic shots like a lot more
action they actually show a lot more
things that are only
um like reported on in the US version
because they couldn't show it or they
couldn't afford it or whatever
um so in that sense I think it's like
better like I said it's like a more
dynamically shot movie but
um the guy that plays dracula is a
little over the top I kind of feel like
um a little bit like Bella Lugosi is
obviously like the OG he's like you know
gonna be way better
um the guy that plays dracula look like
it's cool but he's like a little bit
more like animated you know what I mean
whereas Bella Lugosi is a lot more like
low-key like low-key and like more
creepy and
um you know like the way he moves is
like very deliberate whereas like you
know the guy that plays him in the
Spanish version is a lot more maybe he
never saw a demonstrative maybe he never
saw Bayless performance he didn't what
they did um and this is like really
interesting too so this was apparently
like a pretty common practice back in
the day because you have to think like
this is only 1931 like prior to this
there it was been silent movies and so
you made a silent movie you can show it
all over the world because there's no
dialogue right so it's just you know I
mean you have to do like different
interstitial cards like with different
languages and stuff but they didn't have
to like overdubbing or nothing like that
so when sound films like first came in
they were like well [ __ ] now what are we
gonna do we can't just like you know we
can't just like write some more like you
know title cards and call it a day now
we have to have like a whole other thing
like we have to do it in different
languages so what they got in the habit
of doing was they would shoot the
English language film during the day and
then at night
the Spanish language crew would come in
and they would use the same sets same
costume same script uh and everything
and they would actually like at least
the guy that directed the Spanish
language Dracula he would would watch
the rushes from that day like that Todd
Browning had done he didn't let the he
didn't let the cast see it because he
didn't want them to be influenced by the
American actors performances he wanted
to do their own thing but they wanted to
see what that and they and there is kind
of a story too that like the guy that
directed the Spanish language version
wanted to like make it better yeah so he
was like watching Todd Browning's like
dailies and being like I see what you're
doing there but how about this you know
what I mean so he would do like a more
and sometimes he would like flip the
shot or sometimes he would like but it
was really interesting it's a really
interesting video like seeing how two
directors can come at the same thing
essentially like what's the Spanish
actor look like that played he looks
very similar and matter of fact I think
to save money they used some of Todd
Browning's like shots that he didn't use
in his films so actually some shots like
are far away are Bella Lugosi like if
it's far away and you can't really tell
who it is so the guy actually does you
know from far away it does kind of look
like Bella Lugosi like he has like the
same outfit and the same kind and
everything like that yeah and I'm kind
of interested to see it too like now
that I watched watched it but one thing
I had forgotten like I said because I'm
pretty fairly familiar with the book
and even though I know that the Todd
Browning Dracula was based on the stage
play uh and this and I've actually seen
like a Stage production of it although
I'm not sure if it's the same
as the one that was touring at the time
that the movie came out but I had
forgotten that the whole first part of
the movie
um with it which is at Castle Dracula
isn't Harker it's Renfield yeah and I
had totally forgotten yeah that aspect
yeah I got confused because at first I
was like assuming that was Harker
because you know that's that's how the
book goes like Jonathan Harker he shows
he's a solicitor and he shows up at
Castle Dracula he's gonna sell him some
property or whatever and then when they
said Mr I'm like wait a minute that's
Renfield what's going on and then I was
like oh yeah they did like change that
around they merged the two characters
together I guess they did it well they
didn't though because Harker's in it
later but then the thing about it is
that Harker who was like a big main
character in the book is in the movie
but he's like barely in it yeah so why
put him in there yeah yeah it really
they really didn't even realize how
harca was in it yeah he was okay it's
just that he was like so Bland and like
didn't really do much of anything it's
just like it was really weird like how
much they reduced his role I'm not
really sure why they decided to
I don't know they didn't necessarily
switch the characters because once you
know Dracula gets to England then
Renfield kind of like falls into his
similar role as he did in the book but
and Harker does too
but I'm not really sure what the impetus
was for switching it for making it
Renfield I saw one thing that's like
somebody that commented they said oh
well maybe they did that to give
Renfield like a reason that he was
insane like he was normal and then he
went to Dracula's castle and then
Dracula bit him and made him a thrall or
whatever or made him a slave and that's
what drove him crazy whereas in the book
he was already in the Asylum like he was
already a crazy person and I thought the
implication in the book was that because
he was quote unquote feeble-minded or
was already insane that it was easier
for Dracula to let control his mind and
get him to do [ __ ] that he wanted you
know what I mean so I guess they were
trying to tie that together but it just
seemed weird because like I said then
like then you have Harker and Harker is
in the movie but he doesn't really do
any of the Harker [ __ ] that like he did
the Harker [ __ ] that he did in the book
you know what I mean another thing that
I didn't realize until I saw another
reviewer like point this out
is that in the Bella Lugosi Dracula
um they have like the [ __ ] that happens
with Lucy is like immediate I didn't
even realize that she had been killed
you know what I mean yeah because like
in the book it's a long process yeah
bites her over several like over several
days like it's three days or three or
something like that like it's a while
and then it like takes her a while to
die and then like she comes back as the
blue fur lady and she's like eating
little children and stuff like in the
book I'm talking about but like in the
movie it's basically like she is talking
Amino one night about oh I think
Dracula's kind of hot or whatever and
then literally like the next scene she's
laying in bed you know Dracula comes in
her window and like leans over her and
then literally the next scene she's like
in the autopsy thing yeah and I was like
wait is she dead yeah like in the Morgan
they're doing a thing and they're like
look at the two little marks but they
don't show the little marks you never
see him bite anybody you never see like
a neck with marks on it you never see
that you do see it in the Spanish
version but not in the US there's a lot
of stuff you never see that they talk
about yeah like uh
Dracula's abilities
Renfield says Renfield says that he saw
Dracula coming on like on a wave of
flame but then when it got closer it was
millions of little rat eyes and then he
opened his eyes and he could they were
just like the rat's eyes glowing red but
bigger and then and he came so he came
he came as a swarm of rats all right but
you only you only hear that you never
see it and then Mina says that she woke
up in a room filled with fog and then a
eyes and a face coalesced out of it
so
there there's the the whole vampires can
be can take a Mist form you know so it's
all there but they didn't have any
ability to do any special effects to
show it
the bat
his Bat form is pretty bad well it was
the 30s it was the 30s it was almost not
like they didn't try though like a big
rubber band yeah
it wasn't a very convincing bat
it's a good movie The acting's really
good bailiff Bayla is the [ __ ] star
he [ __ ] slabs it all right
the script is kind of weak it's the the
end is anticlimactic a lot
he just get staked and you don't even
really see that and you don't see it
it's like yeah he shoots it from like
far away and you just kind of see van
helsing's back going oh and then you're
kind of here Bella goes he gets staked
and [ __ ] well they couldn't show it
they couldn't show it and then then they
[ __ ] said okay let's get out of here
[ __ ] roll credits that's it you're
like wait a minute that's the end of
that [ __ ] movie yeah wait what there
was no
big all right look
this is the [ __ ] this was like one of
the greatest vampire movies of all times
that started the whole vampire thing
yeah I mean if the the whole horror
landscape would look completely
different if they totally did this is an
important movie all right uh baylo's
[ __ ]
he's the best Dracula he's the reason to
watch this movie yeah
but man [ __ ] Bride of Frankenstein
blows us out of the water
is a much better so does the mummy Boris
Carlos The Mummy blows this out of the
water and it's in the mummy is a similar
story but it shows a lot more
yeah they got away with a lot more maybe
because this was the first one they were
like afraid they were afraid or
something to show
um certain things because yeah it was
and you could tell it's very very
obvious when you watch it that they're
like I was like oh well I guess they
weren't allowed to show that and they
weren't allowed to show that they
weren't allowed to show anyone's neck
with the bites on it they weren't
allowed to show anybody getting staked
they weren't and that some of the stuff
you could tell was budgetary constraints
like there's one scene where Harker
wearing like the most ridiculous pants
ever
um runs to like the French doors and
he's like look outside like it looks
like a big huge dog like and they're
like oh like a wolf and I'm like it had
been cool to show that but yeah you know
rather than but there's a lot of that
like in the movie where they're just
like talking and so you can tell that
this came from a stage play yeah where
you know obviously they couldn't get a
wolf onto the stage so they're just
gonna have somebody going look a wolf
outside you know what I mean but in a
movie form it doesn't work as well and
what's sad is that there's a lot of
Awesome
Gothic imagery in it but it does it's
not quite enough like there's some
really good [ __ ] but I got Castle
Dracula the way it looks the brides
but they didn't do enough with them they
don't do anything with them you just you
didn't see very much of it
I want to see the Spanish version now
you know and then they go back to Carfax
Abby Carfax Abby is kind of like Castle
Dracula it's similar just a British
version of it and they show some really
cool shots in there
Dracula himself walking Mina around some
good little scenes
Bella what he does with his [ __ ]
hands and his Mesmer his mesmerism and
mental domination over people really
good scenes they're just not enough it's
not enough of it
and then uh
uh the bat transformation uh I think
that was weak even for the 30s they
could have done it a lot more
artistically I think you wouldn't have
to show a damn bat on a wire going
around there's there's there had to been
a better way
to do the bat effect or totally get rid
of the bad effect
um
some of it looks feels just kind of
rushed
if you ask me
I one thing that I remember like I said
and we sound like we're being like
negative and we're not because like I
really do I like this movie a lot yeah
and but I think Bella Lugosi is the best
thing about it but it's like I really
think it's interesting the editing in
this movie is very strange too yeah I
kind of feel and because remember what I
was saying earlier about the whole thing
with Lucy where it's like literally like
there's a shot of Lucy like and you know
Bella will go see like leaning over her
and then like she's on the autopsy table
and I'm just like what the [ __ ] and then
later on like I don't think is there
even a shot of her I think there's one
shot of her like her vampire form like
walking around a cemetery like from far
away but then basically they just have
Mina saying oh I looked and I saw her
like standing there and you know but
then I realized she was dead so they
kind of like hint around at the whole
blooper lady thing where she's like been
vampireized and stuff but I will note
that there was no scene even though it
was in the script because it's in the
Spanish language version and they use
the same script there's no scene where
they kill Lucy so Lucy's apparently
still walking and I didn't even realize
that until I was watching another review
of it and they pointed out they said
yeah they left that plot thread hanging
because you know they very clearly say
that yeah she's walking around like as a
vampire but they don't like in the book
they all the you know all her suitors
like the three the three guys that were
in love with her they go into the Crypt
and like cut her head off yeah to like
you know save her soul or whatever man I
gotta see this Spanish version because
everything I'm hearing about the Spanish
version like that's the movie I really
wanted to see
I mean even when Dracula picks up in
this case it's Redfield it's not yeah
which that confused me for a little
while that confused me at first because
I forgot about that drag the picks up
Renfield when his coach halfway to
Castle Dracula and he goes up and sees
him and it was it was Dracula himself
driving the coach yeah and they show his
face his eyes are all like headlights
[ __ ] that was a great shout out it
looked good but I really like the um uh
the newer version with uh
oh man who went Gary Oldman yeah it was
Gary Oldman win [ __ ] the hand comes
down and goes around his head
and then it was just totally shot out of
[ __ ]
you know what I mean you don't see the
hand connected to anything yeah because
the scale is totally wrong that hand is
big enough to wrap around his whole head
it's just like what the [ __ ] hitting the
coach
and he never even got out of the seat
just grab by the head and put him in and
they and they really should have thought
about stuff like that because they had
the ability to do special effects like
that in 31. that was just a trick a
camera angle and editing to do that you
didn't need a real hand and it was a
fake hand to go around his head like
that or just some really long fingers
the guys you know real long prosthetic
fingers to go around his head like that
just shoot it in a certain way and shoot
his face looking terrified at whoever it
was you know Dracula up there in the
driver's seat
there's a lot of [ __ ] they sh they could
have done talking about the
Dracula riding in on a down wave of
flame but it turned out to be tiny eyes
of rats you know carried him they had
the ability to do animation Back Then I
would like to have seen something like
that you know yeah I kind of feel like
that was what like I said you can tell
but it's very stagey because
um I mean you have to give them a break
too but you have to think that like you
know 1931 film hadn't really been around
all that long and it might not have been
a horror Market well that's well they
didn't know I mean the thing about it
was that you know they'd they'd done
stuff like in the silent era like they
did Phantom of the Opera and Hunchback
of Notre Dame and stuff which aren't
technically horror movies I mean they
kind of have horror elements and those
were like really
um you know popular I kind of feel like
when they were first thinking about
doing Dracula they wanted it to be more
like that but I think that they were
kind of afraid that yeah they weren't
sure how it was going to play because
like I said they're scaring people too
much yeah well and that's the thing and
I think scared
well yeah like like I said the the
Spanish version is like it's still not I
mean it's not scary and it's not like by
today's standards or anything like that
but they did show a lot more they're
showing you what was supposed to happen
because some of the shit's just kind of
vague in in this in the script like I've
forgotten all about
[ __ ] Lucy they never killed Lucy no
they didn't so like I said she's still
so they killed Dracula but she's still
alive like kill a little babies and
whatnot yeah and they left the brides
hanging the brides are just back in
volacia Romania you know Transylvania
you know they're just hanging out you
know making more vampires I guess yeah
going all Countess battery on people
probably they just leave that hanging
yeah but like I'm saying that the um the
whole thing of them killing Lucy that
was in the script because like I said
it's in the Spanish language version so
they left it in but for whatever reason
I don't know if they just forgot about
it or but they cut that out so you it's
just kind of and now I mean to be fair I
didn't realize that they had left that
out because I was like you know getting
into the story and everything but they
did leave that out they left that yeah
hang in yeah that's disturbing yeah
because that's kind of like a big deal
like in the book that's a big deal like
that they all have to like get together
and they're like horrified that they
have to like cut her body up and like
cut her head off and [ __ ] like that but
she was like running around like and
they didn't even talk about it like we
had to go down and kill Lucy yeah they
don't even mention it because some
things that happen in here like they
just mentioned it yeah
um you know and I actually I wasn't even
sure like when Lucy died like so quickly
like after like two scenes or something
and I was like are they even gonna talk
about because I because I said you the
way that the movie was going I said you
can tell that they were really trying
like not to be super controversial and I
was like are they even going to mention
that Lucy came back from the dead as a
vampire and was like killing little kids
and stuff but they did mention it and
they did and Mina did mention seeing her
and I think there was a shot of her if I
remember it correctly like her just like
she doesn't look like vampire or
anything like nobody has fangs in this
that was that was a later uh iteration
but um but she's just like walking
through the darkness or whatever but
then that's the last time you see her
like they don't mention her again and
they don't kill her they don't like you
know yeah we're not bagging on this
movie it's a great movie it's imperfect
it's one of the first of its kind though
and but what makes it great if you ask
me is balagosi's performance
um the Spanish scripts now the Spanish
version sounds better in terms of script
what's on screen I'd like to see it but
Bella's [ __ ] graded it and um he does
a bunch of stuff that I forgot about
like he could change his facial
expression he could look totally
different if he had to from certain
angles like he'd uh he'd look kinda
slimy in certain shots like kind of weak
and oily and then all of a sudden real
cookie and all of a sudden he seemed
like he was a lot stronger he put his
head a certain way you know and use
Mental powers on people so he's kinda
he is an odd guy there's something not
right with him even if he didn't know he
was a vampire he's he's doing weird [ __ ]
yeah he was like way better at playing
like a creepy character yeah like he was
like charming and interesting but he was
a sleaze bag yeah like the way he moved
he moved very very slowly and very
deliberately and he spoke very slowly
and deliberately and I think that really
like informed the character a lot I mean
obviously because I kind of feel like
every Dracula iteration after that was
influenced by him
um he's like a he's like a sleaze ball
that is really well dressed and on his
Best Manners but you got the feeling
that that he's being very formal but you
have the feeling that's not who he is
he's not he's a [ __ ] monster he's
he's a vampire
and he's just the way he moves sometimes
is like
real formal and Stern
and then sometimes he goes animalistic
and then sometimes he's just kind of
creepy
which you kind of get that from Klaus
kinski's performance certain elements of
that in his version of Nosferatu where
he's just slimy and Amy and pitiful I
detected a little bit of that and and
belugosi's performance only in certain
moments
you know like when he introduced himself
he didn't really there's something kind
of odd about him
I really liked the one scene like when
he first gets to England and he's kind
of like walking through the streets like
in his top hat and pain and everything
and literally like the first thing he
does like always walking around the
street is he grabs that girl like that's
there just like selling flowers or
whatever and like takes her behind the
thing they don't show it obviously but
it's implied that she takes that he
takes back there and like kills her
because then they show her dad later on
so I like that they didn't like [ __ ]
around they're like even though he looks
normal and he looks like
you know he's wearing the tux and the
top hat and like nobody thinks he looks
unusual but he's still like a Monster
yeah yeah that's what they were not some
kind of War medal or something yeah
um yeah Hugo said Dwight Fry is an
underrated actor I Dwight Fry was great
in this I kind of feel like him and
Bella Lugosi were like the main reasons
to watch this movie Dwight Frye was the
guy that played Renfield by the way like
as soon as like he goes crazy Dwight
Frye was in Frankenstein dude that
played van helsink was cool though too
yeah and I think that guy was in
Frankenstein too I think that's the same
guy because they used a lot of the same
actors yeah Van Helsing was like a great
character in this too but like I said
it's I just found it kind of strange
that the the kind of the main characters
from the novel were like Jonathan Harker
and Mina and stuff like that really get
relegated to
not I mean Mina gets kind of a bigger
part than Harker does Parker doesn't
like do hardly anything really and like
I said not once they took out the whole
like Lucy like them having to kill Lucy
type of thing and it's almost two here's
another thing I think in the book it
kind of took them a while to come to the
conclusion that it was a vampire right I
mean yeah you know because Lucy they
thought she was dying from Nails I think
Van Helsing like knew what was up but
but he wasn't saying anything about it
whereas this one they were pretty much
like you know as soon as Lucy died Van
Helsing was like oh the bite marks oh
vampire and everybody's like oh okay
vampire they were like all on board with
it I kind of feel like everybody just
like believed it right away which you
know like I said this isn't a long movie
it's only like an hour and 14 minutes so
I guess they were trying to like move
stuff along but it did seem kind of
weird that everyone was just kind of
like on board with oh yeah it's a
vampire but then the weird thing is that
once that they've established oh there's
a vampire that's like you know snacking
on everybody
um you would think that the next
assumption would be like well obviously
it's belugosi because he's the one that
just arrived here uh but they don't
really come to that conclusion but then
when they do
they don't really it seems like to take
them a while to kind of do anything
about it because honestly like Dracula
just comes to I guess it's van helsing's
house I'm not really sure whose house it
is yeah or Dr Seward's house yeah you're
not really sure where you are oh maybe
it's Dr Seward's house because um I
think that it's because doesn't Dr
Seward I think his house is like next to
the sanitarium okay and then and then
like sometimes like uh Renfield like
comes wandering into the house so I'm
assuming it's like next door
oh also I think they made Mina Seward's
daughter in this okay yeah which okay
well I I kind of get why they do that I
know they it's they kind of like make
them related in a lot of different
versions because remember like the
frankly Angela version I think that Van
Helsing was Mina's dad and then Seward
was Lucy's dad or something but then in
the van in the um Frank langella version
which is from 1979 they swapped Mina and
Lucy which I didn't get why they did
that because it didn't really make any
difference but I mean they just switched
their names and characters which I
thought was kind of odd maybe they
didn't know what they were doing
I've seen other versions with it that's
like I don't understand why it's like
I've never seen like I said if you've
seen that cinematic or video where he's
like doing the um the comparisons like
which Dracula movie was like the closest
to the book there is not a single one
that just follows the book it's like
they always have to [ __ ] with it and I
don't understand why that is always like
they either have to like switch
characters around or they have to like
make characters related when they're not
related or and I don't really get it
like sometimes I get it like sometimes I
could think oh if I was a writer like
maybe you'd want to do that but most of
the time it doesn't make any difference
so I don't really know why now from this
moment on Belle the ghost is being
plagued by this character too they
always want him to replay Dracula all
the time but I think a lot of it was
copy still copyrighted at the time they
couldn't do it so they had to rename him
they call them count yorga or some
stupid [ __ ] like that or just the
vampire and
but uh poor Bella was having to do this
[ __ ] wait when he was far too old they'd
have him on game shows trying to dressed
up in his Dracula outfit and poor guy
and I mean technically he really only
played Dracula in this movie and like
one other one yeah the rest of him he's
playing another vampire yeah like he did
play other vampires like technically
non-dracula but it's like I kind of feel
like he just got so that's the thing
like you get Typecast in a role like
that which and we were kind of talking
about this when we were talking about
Frankenstein it was like that it didn't
happen to the same extent to Boris
Karloff like Boris Karloff still played
lots of different kind of characters
whereas Bella Lugosi played this and I
mean the thing about it was that you
have to admit like in Dracula he crushed
it I mean he established that archetype
yeah which is awesome because we still
are talking about him like a hundred
years later but
it wasn't so great for his career
because he got really really stuck in
that and everybody just kept wanting him
to repeat it and it I think it was very
frustrating for him yeah and uh really
my favorite movie with his is the Black
Cat Boris Karloff Bella goes and he
plays a character named Vitus veltigast
vertigast or the felticast or vertigast
stuff like that and he's just he's
released from the cool go which is a
damn military prison he goes back to get
revenge on his commander who did
sacrifice the unit to consecrate the
ground so he could build his evil
satanic Castle on his [ __ ] great
flick man and uh
it's he's not playing Dracula but he's
just playing another character and he's
kind of like playing himself in a way if
you've never seen any
if you ever see any old interviews with
uh Bella
he caught us in character all the time
and
he always kind of seems like Vita
sveltegast whenever he's just talking
but uh yeah see that one he's got a long
a lot of a lot of lines in it you know
he's he's headlining in it right
alongside Carl off good flick that flick
is actually better than this flick I
think the black cat is better than than
this is still a great flick though but I
mean this is one of those movies that I
kind of feel like if you care anything
at all about you know movies as like a
cultural artifact or anything like that
then this is you kind of have to see
this one because this is like I said
this is like the OG Universal monster
this is the thing that makes us this was
the whole like thing that kicked it off
that's why we talk about Universal
monsters still yeah like this many years
later because of this movie and it was
kind of like honestly it was kind of
like a gamble at the time because like I
said prototype they didn't really have
horror movies there weren't a lot of
Silent horror movies or anything like
this they didn't really know how it was
gonna play and I the horror movies that
they did have like were tended to be
more like human monsters like they
didn't want to have like Supernatural
elements if there were Supernatural
elements then you would find out at the
end that they were fake you know what I
mean like that kind of thing because
they were almost kind of like they
didn't want people actually like
believing in the Supernatural or if they
didn't want to encourage it I guess
which is like really funny to think
about nowadays well then treat people
like children back then they did they
also had to moralize everything that the
evil people were always punishing they
always had to get punished and people
were always rewarded right
um they did you know which that was not
good that's not good to teach people
that
um yeah because that because when good
people die the people are [ __ ]
astounded they think they must have done
something wrong no good people die
um and they didn't do anything wrong
they were just in the wrong place at the
wrong time yeah and that sucks but
that's just what it's like and it uh you
could fall under in the clutches of an
evil person they could just kill you no
matter how good you are
and that's something that back then they
didn't really want to talk about but
that's that's always been reality but
when you look at this movie and then you
look at
later on
a Bride of Frankenstein
the horror movie had come a long way
the gothic and it was only four years
yeah because the first well the first
Frankenstein came out in 1931 the same
year as this one because this one was so
massively successful that immediately
they went and did Frankenstein but Bride
of Frankenstein came out in 1939
Frankenstein visually the story The
what's in there what they're talking
about messing with their seeds and [ __ ]
making them homunculous and yeah it's
and
running around in Crips and
it's light years ahead of this they're
they're actually showing you stuff and
it's creepy what they're showing you
real but it's also a real artistic they
got away with a lot yeah and I mean I
will say that James whale was like maybe
a more I mean and I'm not like I I
really liked a lot of Todd Browning's
movies I don't think he made a [ __ ] ton
I remember he made freaks uh which
actually is another movie that everybody
should see
um he got in big trouble for that
actually because he used real circus
freaks yeah in the movie and people were
like fainting in the aisles and whatnot
that's where those people got their
status and their money from though if
they weren't in there yeah you know if
they weren't in them yeah that's the
thing but have a family or a job that
was a scene that was kind it's kind of a
[ __ ] up movie like for the time freaks
we should probably do that with the guy
with no arms and legs holding a knife in
his teeth like he's gonna hurt you that
was a good scene yeah but um yeah this
is a great movie but uh they got better
they got better The Mummy is better
I want to see the Creature from the
Black Lagoon haven't seen that I know
that one was good I remember it being
great when I was a kid and that was like
significantly later yeah that was like
50 50s that was 54 I think that was 50s
and then uh the thing was also 50s
wasn't it yeah yeah I want to see that
I've never seen that
yeah that might be another one I haven't
seen into Wolfman stuff
yeah we probably should do Wolfman
because we've done Frankenstein and now
we're doing Dracula yeah no there's no
sequel to this
no yeah uh the second one is I think the
second one's Dracula's daughter okay and
then there's son of Dracula okay and
it's in the same franchise yeah okay
then I gotta see him Bella's in them
um
wait I don't think he was okay but you
know what I well the thing about it like
Dracula when they were first gonna make
it they actually wanted Lon Chaney to be
in it Lon Chaney was supposed to be
Dracula and I think he was supposed to
be Van Helsing too but he died
so uh they said they were thinking about
some other actors I think they
considered like John Carradine uh Conrad
white who was in uh The Man Who Laughs
in the hands of orlac uh he's great
actually he would have been a good
Dracula probably but I mean you know not
as iconic as Bella Lugosi probably but
um if they didn't really want Bella
Lugosi at first it just happened that
Bella Lugosi had been in the Stage
production which was touring around the
U.S and it so happened that the Stage
production was in LA at the time they
were casting the movie and so they were
like convinced to put Bella Lugosi in
the movie because he was getting like
such good notices for being in the Stage
production but when they asked when they
asked him to be in it
they said they'd only let him be in it
if he like took a pay cut
so he only made this movie
um took seven weeks to shoot and he only
made 3 500 like he got paid less than
the dude I think his name was David
manners the dude that played Harker even
though Harker is barely in the [ __ ] and
like doesn't do anything like I wouldn't
say Harker's barely in it it's just that
the first part of the movie like I said
that normally would have been Harker
because that's how it was in the book
and that's how most other adaptations of
it were was Renfield which was Dwight
Frye who was great but then like once
they get to England and you know Harker
gets more into the story he doesn't
really do a lot I mean it seems like
it's mostly
I mean you probably could have taken him
out and I don't think it would have made
a difference what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
did you hear that yeah what up you doing
you Buffalo herder
hurting oh she's hurt when she runs she
did that at like five o'clock this
morning too did you hear it she smacks
the ground with all four feet she gets
down real low she's not even standing up
she's barely rubbing across the
floorboard
it's like that's she probably only
weighs like 10 pounds if that and it's
like she sounds like a whole like
[ __ ] herd like running across the
floor we're here in the middle of the
night she'll run through the whole top
floor
[Laughter]
making noise the whole time they call
that the Zoomies that's what they call
that uh Zach says I still say the best
Dracula movie is the Gary Oldman movie I
honestly really really love the Gary
Oldman movie and it is actually like a
lot more faithful to the book I like
Dracula Untold yes that way yeah
somebody said about that too like yeah
Danny rolling said about that yeah I
like that one although that wasn't
really I mean that was more based on
Vlad the Impaler yeah like that wasn't
actually they merged it all together yes
which that was a later thing I've
there's been like I think as far as I
know there's like a lot of back and
forth about how much of Vlad the Impaler
that Bram Stoker like put into the novel
like he did know about Vlad the Impaler
and he did put some details about that
like in the book but I don't think that
Dracula was supposed to be Vlad the
Impaler Dracula Untold is kind of like
Dracula's origin story yeah what he did
back when he was Vlad the Impaler that's
how I remembered it but I've only seen
it once I have it on Blu-ray I gotta go
watch it again
I remember liking it though I think it's
like a prequel to this
yeah kinda yeah Sean what he did back in
the 1500s or the 1400s with the Turks
this one um this Bella Lugosi one it
doesn't really go a lot into
his history like Dracula's history does
it because I kind of feel like in the
novel like he talks a lot about City
centuries old right yeah but I think
basically all he says and he even says
that kind of obliquely because he even
says to Van Helsing in this movie he's
like oh you're a wise man for somebody
that's only lived one lifetime or
something like that so he implies that
he's you know been around a long time
but he doesn't really go a lot into his
history whereas in the book he does and
I think in a lot of the other uh movies
he does but like I said I think there
was more of his origin a little bit like
in the script because I think they
talked a little bit more about it in the
Spanish language version so which like I
said was the exact same script but they
left a lot more stuff in I gotta see
that where can we see it I don't know I
have to like look it up I think like
like I said I haven't watched the whole
thing on you straight through but I was
like watching like clips of it because
it was a really good video that did like
a comparison that was talking about all
the Shot differences and stuff and he
was basically saying that in terms I
mean in his opinion he was like as far
as you know Dracula Bella Lugosi he's
like and as far as like the atmosphere
that he thinks the American one was
better but he's like as far as how the
shots were staged
um you know kind of like the the
dynamism like I said of the shots it was
more action there was more he's like and
I'm not saying that the Spanish language
one was like you know didn't have slow
bits because it did it's like a lot
longer and some of of the you know just
like in the American version like
sometimes the scenes went on kind of
longer were very stagey or static but
he's like the American version like a
lot of the shots were again like very
static whereas they were a lot more
Dynamic like in the Spanish language it
was real effective though like when yeah
when um when Dragon was trying to
dominate uh mentally dominate van
helsick when he says come here the [ __ ]
yeah
he's in [ __ ] van helsink is [ __ ]
trying to resist it you're like is he
good is he gonna go is he gonna go no he
eventually goes
you have very strong will
yeah
but it
was so I do kind of feel like
there was a lot of like kind of static
stuff and a lot of stuff that they
probably could have shown rather than
just like talking about it like that you
know what I mean but you know that's
kind of betraying its Origins as like a
stage player rather than yeah being like
a direct adaptation of the novel so I'm
not gonna get too mad about it
um but I don't know so yeah I would be
kind of interested to see that like from
what I could see of the guy and I can't
remember the actor's name that played
Dracula in the Spanish language version
but um he did look a lot like Bella
Lugosi but he was like I said he was a
lot more animated and I kind of feel
like Bella Lugosi being very still and
very deliberate was like a lot creepier
like he came across as like a lot more
threatening I kind of feel like
um you know which is why that
performance is so iconic and you know
just like the way he talked and
everything was was like a lot creepier
yeah I mean there have been portrayals
of vampires where the guy didn't even
say anything and it was [ __ ] powerful
like a skinny guy from uh Salem's Lot
who played uh Mr Barlow Barlow yeah he
just came in they've crashed through the
window like a damn ball and hit the
ground like a flat piece of sheet and
then just stood up with it man what a
great scene that was yeah he didn't say
anything you know yeah just weird [ __ ]
he had [ __ ] he had that his uh his
servant do all the Talking for him see I
would argue and we've talked about this
before I would argue that it's a lot of
times your monster it's scarier if they
don't talk yeah
scare if they don't talk and actually I
was kind of thinking about it today
because
um I have a video that's going up later
this week where I'm going to be talking
about the um the Dario Argento movie
mother of Tears uh you know the third
and the three mothers Trilogy and I
think one of the mistakes of the many
that he made in that movie was that uh
the witch like the main witch villain
talks and I'm like she's not in it a lot
but I really wish I'm like that really
really kind of
it really lessens your Menace when
you're talking usually not always I mean
obviously it depends on what you're
talking about if I'm talking more about
like Monsters you know monsters if you
have something that's like a serial
killer like you know you know Hannibal
Lecter or something like that obviously
a lot of his Menace comes from him
talking and like what he says because of
the psychological psychological like
mind [ __ ] that he pulls on you but I
kind of feel like when you have a
monster like Mr Barlow
even though he did talk in the book
didn't he uh yeah he talked to him he's
spoken the book yeah see I think I think
that was so I think that was absolutely
the right call by Toby Hooper like when
they did the adaptation to have Mr
Barlow not talk it's much scarier when
he doesn't talk yeah he had his uh
servant do all the Talking for him I've
got what that guy's name was guy who ran
the antique shop yeah yeah so that way
you could
and you know and they were very
different looking you had one guy who
was just like kind of this eloquent Old
Gentleman with the damn mustache damn
Derby and this other guy that looked
like like a Nosferatu I look a bluish
Nosferatu that crawled out of a crypt
somewhere
in a rag if I remember it wasn't it
wasn't he there wasn't really in rags
was he was just in a a black cloak yeah
something like a black cloak I don't
even think it had a hood on it though
just a
creepy dude yeah
but I think like the best thing about
this I think is just the way that
the bill of Lugosi moves and the way
that he talks even though he talks like
he's still creepy because there's just a
lot of shots of just his face like
looking and it it looks really good
another thing that I had forgotten about
was that this movie The version that we
watched and I'll get into this in a
minute but
um the it didn't have a score
did you notice that like it's it's quiet
like through the whole thing
um so it was almost like a silent movie
in some ways like obviously it has
dialogue and [ __ ] like that but there's
long stretches of it where nobody talks
and there's no music which is makes it a
little bit creepier I kind of feel like
just had music at the beginning in India
yeah it just had like the Swan Lake uh
this one like the Tchaikovsky music yeah
that at the beginning but like other
than that there's no music in it so a
lot of the scenes like the scene where
they first introduced Dracula where he's
coming out of the coffin and like the
the brides are down in the Crypt or
whatever yeah it's just like it's silent
like they just kind of come toward the
camera and there's like no there's no
music or no sound
um in 1998
a very famous uh classical composer
Philip Glass did a score for this movie
so if you buy it now like on DVD or
Blu-ray or something like that it
usually has an alternate track where you
can watch it with Philip glass's score
on it some people like it some people
don't I mean I really like Philip Glass
I like I've always liked his music I
remember I really like the music that he
did for uh the original like Candyman
the Clive Barker one uh I love that but
um didn't he koyana Scotty I think he
did Coya Scotty too now that I'm
thinking about it but that was also
great but so I haven't heard like the
score for this but he did write a score
like specifically for this because it
didn't have one because like I said you
know this was only a couple years out
from the silent film era so they weren't
used to movies having scores although
what they would do like silent movies is
they would have like a live person there
like they'd have a piano and they'd
sometimes like play like you know what I
mean like if [ __ ] was going on so I
guess they didn't really get their [ __ ]
together enough to like have the movie
have a score but yeah it was like
I I don't know I think in some ways that
kind of makes it creepier because like
some scenes are just like there's
nothing and there's like just long
scenes of his like creepy looking face
like he's looking all like intense and
[ __ ] like that
I just always kind of associate these
movies with my childhood yeah because I
was able to see him on TV and when I was
young like damn you know eight nine ten
they played him on television
a lot of times we a lot of times early
in the morning before the cartoons I
think or maybe it was after the cartoons
I don't remember sometimes it was dark
when they were on because I think I
would get up at like five o'clock in the
morning because cartoons came on at six
yeah and at five they were playing this
kind of stuff before the sun came up and
they were
they were just they weren't very
complicated so a kid could understand
what the hell was going on
I was like woo and I always kind of felt
relieved that they would never really
show anything that I couldn't handle
you know what I mean yeah because I knew
that more modern movies you know of the
of the 70s you know what I'm talking
about showed you know Gore yeah you
never knew what you were going to see
because there was some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening in some 70s movies
but I remember seeing this one and not
really knowing what a vampire was
when I saw the movie they explained it
oh okay they come out of the ground
and then I asked for a model of uh
Dracula they made it in the 70s they
made a model of Dracula and Anne
Frankenstein their faces glowed yeah
Aurora Aurora made yeah I had that and
the hands and the face with glow on it
and I think I painted them and if you
still had those you'd be like yeah I'd
had that up let's go for a lot of money
now I had them up on my dresser and [ __ ]
at night so I would look over there and
see the glowing hands and face and get
creeped up
the other way you don't look back and
Dracula's still there you know like yeah
okay I think I had the Frankenstein too
but I got that one separate and I think
there was a Creature from the Black
Lagoon and a mummy yeah I remember I
think they were all they were they were
they were models those are highly sought
after but there's items yeah collectors
yeah okay look at Pookie she was she was
just back there staring up at the
ceiling fan for like a really long time
um but yeah oh another thing I was gonna
like I thought this was really funny so
we were watching the movie last night
like the scene toward the beginning when
Renfield first gets to it's actually
Hungary like in the movie It's
everybody's speaking Hungarian so uh so
Renfield gets there and they're like
yeah we don't really want to take you
any farther because it's you know it's
getting dark and it's like scary up
there because there's vampires and he's
just like whatever man I have to get up
there to like [ __ ] do my business or
whatever
um so the driver like takes him in the
carriage and he's supposed to he said I
have to meet you know Count Dracula or
whatever at the Borgo pass and so
they're gonna have somebody like pick
him up and then like for the longest
time you know the scene where
you know the carriage with Harker and uh
Renfield see what I'm doing
um with Renfield in it like goes up
toward the Borgo pass and then he meets
up with Dracula's carriage and Dracula's
you know driving the carriage although
he doesn't know who that is or anything
and then and Tom was so confused yeah
for like the longest time because he's
like well wait a minute why is Dracula I
thought he Dracula was just in the
castle and then he was watching The
Carriage come there so why so I didn't
really understand like why you were
confused at first because we had to like
back it up and he had to watch the scene
again yeah because he was like the way
it was edited it looked like he was
standing on the front of his porch
watching the damn Dracula standing on
the porch yeah he's sitting on the porch
that's what it looked like in the rocket
chair yeah and here comes the carriage
and it's pulling up next to his other
carriage in the driveway
that's how I that's how I saw that and I
was like what no he's like he's like
wait what yeah how did he get down there
you know he's already there you know I
was like no he's not the castle he's a
Borgo pass I said well I guess because
you weren't listening to the dialogue
because he said he had to take this
first Carriage to Borgo pass and then to
switch off yeah and then he was going to
get switched because Dracula's Carriage
was gonna pick him up because presumably
The Carriage driver from the town
wouldn't go all the way up to Castle
Dracula because they were scared of the
place so he would need to come down and
pick him up like out of there exactly
wasn't in the damn Carriage though he
was leaning up against a wall see and I
thought he wasn't leaning against the
wall he was on the he was on the
carriage the top of the carriage driving
it
okay I thought he was watching it happen
no no the way they edited it it looked
like he was leaning up against a wall or
something and watching watching no he
was up on those things and he turned
around like looking at yeah at him down
there because the things are static and
it's hard to know sometimes who is where
in space and it because they're doing
cuts and they're obviously not in the
same location anyway you know but I mean
this was edited weird I will give you
that but
um it wasn't but it still wasn't
confusing to me now I will say that the
editing did confuse me a couple times
like especially like when Lucy died I'm
like wait what she's dead already I was
like what happened to the whole like and
then never killed her vampire and then
yeah but it was like that I didn't even
realize that until later until I was
like watching another review and then I
was like wait [ __ ] Yeah you mentioned it
like yeah that's right they never did
like resolve that plot point right which
is crazy well we've seen it we've heard
the story so many times through other
iterations of it that I assumed they
killed her but
which like I said maybe I just assumed
yeah they didn't even mention it that's
what I said I just assumed because I'm
so familiar with the story that it's
like well yeah duh obviously they would
just like go and kill her but they
didn't even say anything about it right
uh Pat Hatfield said I was just about to
ask if there were any hunger fans I love
them yeah uh that's actually probably
one of my favorite it's probably one of
my favorite vampires and they're talking
about count yoga and uh the Blacula
series those two black in the movies are
[ __ ] great too yeah they kick ass
those are relaxing extreme black in the
screen those are good vampire movies
yeah those are really really good that
was those two uh stories were more
instrumental in uh Anne Rice's vampire
Chronicles because that that those
movies cover more of what vampire
culture was even though there are
different versions of those movies and
the the ones that I've seen now I've
screamed but I get a scream a lot of
it's been edited out because there was a
bunch of slavery references to it that
they took out of there because vampires
were Blacula became what he hated most
he was a slaver basically he was making
slaves people with the slaves that's
what that's what vampire thralls were
you know slaves
because I'm a slave now because yes
[ __ ] and he and he got killed behind
trying to stop the slave trade uh uh uh
[ __ ] between
the nobility of of Africa and Europe
and uh he didn't know it but the dude
that he was talking to who was behind
the European slave trade was Dracula
it was Dracula it was behind it
and he turned him into a vampire and
[ __ ] says I'm gonna I'm gonna curse
you with my disease and [ __ ] and I'd
name you Blacula that's yeah that's how
he got the name so he didn't make that
effort because he wasn't given to
himself Dracula called it that yeah and
it was like an insult it's like an
insult yeah Zach says uh also my dad
just saw you on my phone while making
dinner his reaction who are these guys
it's almost a long story that's a long
story yeah uh uh Hugo says after
watching Universal monsters you guys
should watch Van Helsing 2004. I did not
like that movie like I remember I didn't
like um somebody loaned it to me and I'm
not a big fan of those kind of like
action horror movies that kind of
started to come about like in the 90s
and mid-2000s with like all the CGI and
[ __ ] I just wasn't really a fan as I
don't really like underworld I don't
really like any of that stuff yeah I
don't like I don't really like the
action horror hybrid before we move too
far away I'm gonna say go watch black
the black the two black in the movies I
got them both on Blu-ray they might both
be on 2B yeah no you kind of the second
one they've kind of dumbed it down a
little bit it cut some stuff out of it
but
they're still good movies I like the
second one because it's got like that
Voodoo way yeah it's got the voodoo
angle that's how they brought that's how
they brought Momo balde back or black
and his real name is Mama Waldy they
brought it back using Voodoo and uh but
that's where a lot of the Anne Rice got
a lot of her ideas from The Vampire
Chronicles of vampire culture about how
a vampire could just show up and become
rich all of a sudden and say well how do
you get rich like this
well that's because he found a rich dude
and turned him into a vampire made him
his slave and took over his house that's
usually how they did it and then he'd
start making a whole dab
crew of vampires to
thralls and vampires to serve you and
and vampire uh [ __ ] no harem's of
vampire girls and stuff
and it's never really mentioned whether
or not to have sex I don't think they do
have sex and I think Ann writes I think
Anne Rice got that right drinking blood
was sex to them they didn't have sex I
mean I'm pretty sure that was the
implication of vampires going back to
Bram Stoker at least well actually even
before that because
um carmilla which which by Sheridan
lymphede that came out before Dracula
yeah and that was I don't know if it was
explicit but it was like fairly explicit
for the time and honestly like the novel
of Dracula was pretty I mean by today by
Victorian standards was like pretty
smutty like some of the implication in
it well they're eating and reproducing
with blood right so it's kind of like
the same thing it's the same thing so I
think Victorian audiences would have
understood that as like a sexual yeah
metaphor I would think yeah but there
was no copulation
which is why I didn't like the new that
that first new episode of uh interview
of the vampire we saw they made a lot of
mistakes it's going too far away from
from Anne Rice's concept they're showing
the vampires as gay having sex they
didn't have sex they just drank blood
that's what that's sex was that for them
they were all in love with each other
but they were all the same species they
were all the same gender they were I
guess you could say they were gendered
non-binary once you became a vampire
that was it they were all the same
gender
but there wasn't any sex as you would
know it they were totally different
but they were also kind of like
emotional they were all about love and
hate and loyalty and who betrayed who
and who's going to spend time with who
they were attention [ __ ]
you know because that's the only thing
you would value if you live forever
you know how much time will you spend
with me what could you teach me
that's that's the only thing they
worried about think you know what I mean
because that would be a high priority
yeah you know
slasher Fred said one of these days you
should review the two House of Wax
movies mystery of the wax museum and
House of Wax from 1953 with Vincent
Price I would actually did we do those
oh maybe not I kind of thought we did
but maybe not
um and then somebody said oh slasher
Fred also says there's an underrated
movie called Martin which is about this
guy who's convinced he's a vampire yeah
that's George Romero uh we reviewed that
a very long time ago
um I think before we even had a video
component I think that was an audio only
but yeah we did that a really long time
I really really like Martin and yeah I
kind of feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it it's it's very very
underrated like I said
uh let's see I'm trying I got behind you
know what I mean and
Zach says um
uh talking about movie like talking
about the Resident Evil movies even
though they suck but it'd be fun to
watch us talk about them
uh Pat Hatfield said I haven't seen
innocent blood in a long time I kind of
remember that one but I think I only saw
it once so I don't remember that much
about it anybody like Vamp uh we
reviewed that was pretty good we
reviewed that yeah with Grace Jones
Grace Jones yeah
um maybe like a year ago yeah maybe not
even that long ago it was fairly
recently what was so funny about Grace
Jones is that
I thought she was gorgeous but I was
like man she's not my type she's too
tall and skinny turns out she was only
like five foot three
yeah didn't she seem like she'd be tall
yeah I guess it was just like her build
she came across as someone that was like
very tall and like statue-esque yeah and
it just is the way that they shot her
you know what I mean and like just I
guess the stuff that they put her in I
always thought she was like
six feet five ten no she's a little itty
bitty thing
but she didn't come across that way in
the movies she came across as like
Larger than Life
and weird but I liked her she was cool
speaking of heights that was another
thing that I remembered about this about
Dracula is that there's a shot in this
movie where Bella Lugosi when he comes
up to the um where they're at the
symphony and he comes up to the to the
box like and he's talking to um to Dr
Seward and them
and they shoot it so that Bella Lugosi
looks much shorter than the actor
playing Dr Seward and I'm not entirely
sure why they shot it like that because
remember when we did the show not too
long ago about Bella Lugosi and Boris
Karloff and you are surprised that Bella
gossi was like six foot one yeah because
he looks short but and that's why I
think that's why because you're so used
to seeing he was shot in this movie and
he looked short which is really weird
because he was like the same height or a
little bit taller yeah I think than the
actor that played Dr Seward but the way
that they shot it like Dr Seward was
like up here
which is weird you'd think they'd want
him to look bigger like more
intimidating and monstrous but they
didn't do that even in the black cat he
looks like he's shorter than uh than uh
than Carla and I think they were about
the same the same height yeah
that's what I mean that's that's what's
kind of strange you always have an and
maybe too because it's because Carla
played Frankenstein's monster and they
put those big like lift shoes on him so
you're used to him being like a big and
they had like all the stuff like in his
clothing that made him like bigger yeah
if you guys haven't seen the mummy see
the mummy the mummy's it was much better
I just I the first time I'd seen it was
only just a couple days back it's like
Dracula it's karloff's response to
Dracula if you ask me it's a very
similar story but it's an Egyptian Motif
real good real good liked it better than
Dracula I would have to say technically
and the special effects the acting the
story's better the edits better I think
it has a score if I remember correctly
um
it's a better movie uh is it Bella
Lugosi doing dragon that no it's not
it's just they're their own things but
technically I think
mummy was better if you want that
European dark Gothic horror look
you want brighter Frankenstein so far
everything that I remembered from these
old movies as a kid came from that movie
yeah everything I remembered about Dr uh
uh everything that I remembered about
Frankenstein came from that movie I
thought it came from the first one no I
came to the second one
it's like the difference between alien
and aliens or Terminator 1 and
Terminator 2.
a lot of that Gothic dark Gothic spooky
imagery and [ __ ]
everything that I remember as a kid that
that's from
Brian Frankenstein
it's great yeah I think of all the ones
we've watched I mean they all have
something to recommend them but all all
the ones that we've rewatched recently
at bride of Frankincense is like easily
the best one yeah but this movie offers
this Baylor Lugosi he's [ __ ] knocks
it out of the park and [ __ ] crushes
it and Dwight Fry's great in this too
yeah he crushes it I mean he's the main
attraction of this movie yeah that
there's some good ideas but they don't
really develop them like the vampire
Brides his Harem there should have been
more of that and there should they
should have been characters in the story
uh which they are I think in the books
and then and then in some of the other
movies they uh they bite the [ __ ]
realtor and try to enslave his ass and
track that gets jealous and goes down I
think it kills more one or two of them
don't he
I thought he killed one of them and
um
and uh Brent and Bram Stoker's Dracula
or did he just knock her away I think he
just knocked her just knocked her away
okay well because they came in and they
were gonna eat Jonathan yeah and he was
like no that's that's mine here here's a
baby that's right throw him back he
threw a baby in a bag all right for some
reason I thought he's killed one of them
I don't think he just smacked her and
she flew up on again and and flew up on
held onto the wall or the ceiling or
something and ran from him something
like that
John Smith said fun fact in Bram
Stoker's obituary it never mentions
Dracula once in his lifetime he was
mainly known for working in theater
management yeah that's true and it
mentions also author of several novels
isn't that funny and that's like pretty
much the only thing he's like really
remembered for like broadly nowadays uh
Danny rolling said yeah you did review
House of Wax I thought we did because I
thought we watched it like not too long
ago
um let me see they're talking about From
Dusk Till Dawn uh Pat Hatfield said I
thought Dracula's Daughter which is the
one after this uh was a lot better maybe
you could two could review that unless
you already did yeah I don't think we've
done Dracula's daughter
um and I think there was like I said Son
of Dracula is the third one that's on 2B
as well slasher Fred pointed I forgot to
point this out in the scene where
Dracula first arises from his coffin
there's a scene where a beetle comes out
of a little tiny car yeah yeah yeah yeah
we were like we were like wait a minute
what I thought it was a b because he had
a stripy butt it's it's actually a a
potato bug yeah we have a call potato
bug but that's cute that he had like his
own little yeah
and they don't explain it like or
vegetative
I was just kind of like okay whatever uh
and then they're talking about the
original Fright Night is a great 80s
movie I agree one of my uh favorite
horror comedies big time actually a
couple years back for Halloween
was not this past Halloween obviously
but I think it was the Halloween before
I dressed up as vampire Amy from Fright
Night from the original Fright Night
um BBC did a Dracula recently it's on
Netflix it's pretty cool
yeah I mean I like all of the uh
versions and I think the BBC did one in
I want to say it was the 70s maybe 1978
that's supposedly like the most faithful
to the novel
um even though they did change some
stuff because everybody does but yeah so
but like I said but because I hadn't
seen this 1931 version in such a long
time I forgot how much it was more based
on the play and I had totally forgotten
about the whole Harker Renfield
Switcheroo so yeah so that was like
really confusing me like for the first
10 minutes of the movie I'm like wait
who is this now why is this Renfield uh
go ahead and hit the like button if you
will people that'll help us out in the
algorithms and uh super chats are active
if you want to drop Jenny a Super Chat
just uh go ahead and
jopper one and uh we'll give you a shout
out
yeah Daniel let's talk about Lost Boys
that's also another great 80s vampire
movie
um yeah I would like to see like the new
Dracula I kind of wait did I start
watching it I don't know I don't
remember if I did I thought I started
watching like a Dracula thing recently
like a series
uh Daniel Rowling said the Fright Night
remake is good I'm kind of like
I'm debated like whether I want to watch
it or not because I love the original
Fright Night so much that I just don't
think that the Remake could live up to
it
so I don't know I mean if it's good I
might give it a whirl one of these days
but you know remakes are risky man
yeah and I like I said I don't [ __ ] on
them like just across the board you know
but if I really really liked a movie a
lot yeah
um then I'm usually pretty reluctant
like to see the Remake because I'm like
man if you [ __ ] it up it's gonna like
tank my hole they're they're considering
remaking the original Star Wars Trilogy
that's gonna [ __ ] that's gonna be a
cluster [ __ ] well I don't know why they
would bother because people still watch
this still watch the old ones yeah like
I said if you're gonna remake a movie
yeah remake something that was a good
idea but they [ __ ] up the first time
their [ __ ] Lucas did to The Originals
though that [ __ ] them up like the
original emperor
they they should have left that scene in
there they shouldn't have gone back and
changed anything just let them let them
yeah he likes to Tinker I'm gonna go
back and change I mean I know it's his
movies and he can do what he wants to
but it's just kind of like what you know
it's like that's that's so much part of
the culture now yeah but I just I don't
know I could think of like a million
well one I could think of like a million
novels that could probably be adapted if
you're looking for something to you know
like that if you don't want to have to
like write an original screenplay but if
you must do a remake I could think of
lots and lots of movies like from the
you know from the 30s right up actually
from the silent era like right up until
today that were like great ideas but you
know maybe they didn't have the budget
or maybe they didn't you know maybe
something else went wrong with it that
you know or maybe because of like you
know censorship rules or something like
that but now you could make it and you
know so there's really no reason to take
a movie that was awesome the first time
like Fright Night from 1985 and remake
it even if the remake make is good I
just don't really see the point of it I
was like if you're gonna remake
something take a movie from the 80s that
was like okay but not that great or kind
of shitty but had like a good idea
behind it and remake that instead and
like make it better if you can't make it
better then don't bother I just don't
weirdo says that uh Grace Jones comes
back between somewhere between five
eight five ten for some reason I was
thinking that she was a lot shorter
I thought she was tall but then I came
across something that said no she was
wasn't there wasn't it something uh
when we were doing vamp
didn't we dig up some [ __ ] I don't
remember you saying that she was that
short but I I know that's a lot shorter
than I thought she was I thought it was
because we just talked about Vamp like
not that long ago right you know because
we were talking about it recently but
because she had a reputation for being
tall and skinny yeah but then somebody
said somebody said later on
when we were doing research for for Vamp
that no she was small
like five three five four five five
around that around that size I don't
remember yeah I don't remember okay
Danny rolling said uh remake house on
the edge of the Park yeah see I mean
they there's like a million movies that
especially like during the exploitation
era and stuff like that there were like
really cool ideas but they didn't really
have the money or the wherewithal to do
it maybe as well as they wanted to so I
kind of feel like and I'm not saying
that sometimes because look The Dawn of
the Dead remake from 2004 which I
thought was gonna was actually really
good I was like I was surprised at like
how good it was so it can be done yeah I
didn't mind the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
remake it didn't need to be made but it
was fine it was okay
um you know so it can be done like Hills
Have Eyes somebody mentioned Hills Have
Eyes remake was good yeah that was good
so it doesn't necessarily have to be a
bad movie but I just think that that's
probably more Pat Hatfields to mention
that he adored the black cat Beluga
that's my favorite belugosi movie
actually black cat
that's a good one yeah yeah
that's that's the best uh yeah it's the
best one with him in it and Karloff
just a [ __ ] weird flick man we should
probably do like white zombie one of
these days too yeah like what Bella goes
saying it okay slasher friend said if
you guys ever see that movie Bordello of
Blood yeah I've seen that I don't think
we reviewed it but we did demon knight
but I don't think we've done Bordello
blood the other Tales from Crypt movie
uh both Chris Sarandon and Corey Feldman
reversed their roles in Fright Night In
The Lost Boys yeah that's right that's
right I remember bordella blood being a
lot of fun like you know what I mean I
didn't like it I think I liked demon
knight better just because it was
weirder but and that and that [ __ ]
dude is in it that
[ __ ] put the sponge coming out of his
mouth that that's that was like [ __ ]
Larry we just reviewed that not too long
ago but I don't think we've done
Bordello with blood yet I remember
Bordeaux blood being
um goofy but I'd have to see it again
well it's like I said it was the Tales
from the Crypt movie so it's gonna have
Tales from the Crypt was kind of more
known for being I don't know if some
straight up horror comedy but kind of
horror comedy but like super super gory
that was like one of their things was
like it has to be super gory and fun and
kind of funny so I kind of feel like
um would you guys ever review the 1996
film fear is that the one the Thriller
with um uh what's his face was it did
not that was an Alicia Silverstone was
it and uh Wahlberg
was is that the movie that you're
talking about
because I remember that being good it
was like kind of like a stalker Thriller
type situation yeah we might review that
one of these days
um and then Hugo says I like let me in
better than the original I liked him but
I think I like the original better but
um but the Remake was actually like
decent or like the um the American
version
uh Pat says John Carradine did
eventually play Dracula in some pretty
inconsequential films yeah that's right
um yeah Mark Wahlberg that's right
that's that's what I was reading yeah I
saw that I remember that being all right
all right so um we've been going for
like an hour and a half you want to wrap
it up or you have something else to talk
about no that's it we can we can shut it
down okay so um anyway speaking of
horror movies the main show tomorrow
night we are revisiting a topic that we
did a very very long time ago uh video
nasties we're going to be talking about
the whole 80s home video boom in horror
and like all the weird censorship that
they had with all those like
exploitation movies uh so I'm very
excited because that's like always a
topic that I like to talk about so we're
going to be talking about that uh
tomorrow Richard Brown said have you
seen the Bella film dark eyes of London
I don't think I have actually that's one
that I haven't seen I've seen a lot of
his movies but there's a lot that I
haven't seen too you know what I mean
and what looking at him when we were
doing the show about Bella Lugosi and
Boris Karloff like looking at all of
their movies that they'd been in I was
like holy [ __ ] there's like I there's a
lot that I haven't seen so I really need
to get on that but you know
I only have so much time but I I do try
to like see all of that stuff all right
so hopefully you guys can join us for
the show about video nasties tomorrow
night that should be a fun one uh so
yeah have a good rest of your evening
you guys and we'll see you again
tomorrow
bye